>> Alright, so that wasn't so bad. You are able
to compute some probabilities from this joint distribution. So let's
see what happens when we start talking about more variables.
More propositions that could be true or false. What I did
is I filled in thunder as another variable and thunder
can be true or false in each of these cases. And
I wrote down what the probabilities could be from my
experience in Atlanta in the summer. I was, I was around
over last summer, and in 2004, so let's, so I'm an expert obviously, so
I'm able to estimate these probabilities to
the nearest percent. Anyway the point is, that
one of the things you should notice here is that each time we add
one variable what happens to the number
of probabilities that we have to write down?
>> Well in a world where it's binary it goes up by two.
>> A factor of two, right?
>> A factor of two.
>> Not just, not just two more, but like, twice as many. And so
if we have a complicated scenario that we want to be able to reason about,
and it's got, I don't know, a hundred variables, that's going to be a lot.
>> That's, that's, I can't even, I can't even think about that.
>> Yeah, it's like two to the hundred is.
>> That's, that's not even a real number.
>> It's technically a real number, but
it's an, it's an unimaginably large number.
>> There's only like four numbers, one, two, three, many, and too many.
>> So it's going to be really inconvenient as we start adding more
of these and especially if we add
variables like, you know, remember the restaurant
example that we worked on when we were doing decision trees.
>> Oh yeah those were the days.
>> Then there was variables like food type,
and what was the deal with food type?
>> It had lots of values that it could take on.
>> Yeah, yeah like five or something like that.
>> Thai an, American and Italian.
>> Right and so if we had, add variable like that it's going
to multiply the number of probabilities that we need by five. So this is
going to get really big really fast. So would it be nice if
we had an more convenient way of writing it out in this distribution?
>> Yeah, it would be nice.
>> So it turns out that we can factor it.
>> But I thought we already had a factor of two?
>> Well that was a joke but it actually is pretty close to
being the truth, which is the idea that instead of representing all, so,
so, in this case, there's eight numbers. Instead of representing them as eight
numbers, we're going to represent it by you know, 2 times 2 time 2.
So we really are going to essentially factor it. putting,
putting things into pieces that we can recombine, smaller pieces
that we can recombine into, into larger pieces. And it,
yeah, it turns out that actually works out really well.